good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toes happy hump day this is
your host claudia ASHRAE sitting down
with one of my favorite people on planet
even though she did workout this morning
and I don't know who she is her name is
Jackie hey Jax Wow hi I'm through I let
you have the GMM this morning I wasn't
sure how you were gonna handle it um and
that was just a really lovely
introduction one of your favorite people
on planet yeah I kind of fumbled over my
words I usually wake up at 10:30 to
record at 11:00
I literally rolled out of bed two
minutes ago Wow
I mean you got to do what you got to do
I had the opposite morning I just want
to take everyone through it because I
feel like people are on this journey
with me
because I use it on my Instagram story
yesterday because usually my day goes I
wake up have coffee do my makeup and
pick the stories and then we go live and
then after we go live sometimes I'm like
mmm that wasn't my best then I'll work
out and after I work out like some of
the instructors on palette on are so
inspiring and just like get you in your
feels and then like I feel really good
and I'm like this is the way I want to
feel this is the way you should feel
your whole life that's the way you
should feel your whole life that is a
quote from Paper Towns starring Cara
Delevingne it's one of Claudia's
favorite quotes
never saw the movie but the commercial
was really aggressive with Cara
Delevingne that's the why you should
fail you're a ho laughs so taking that
into account I was like what if I
started working out before the toast so
this morning I woke up like an hour and
a half earlier so that I could work out
and shower and have time to do all the
things that I need to do and I just want
to say um this the hypothesis was not
proven to be true first of all I and I
really remember I used to try to do
SoulCycle classes in the morning so I
thought the same thing start my day put
a pep in my step
get my metabolism boosted but here's the
problem I'm not a morning person and I
get really tired in the morning and so
my like my total output on the peloton
class I just did was garbage like I
thought I was working hard but it wasn't
that hard enough because I was just too
damn tired so it's better
and I wait till later in the day when
I've had like something to eat and I
just have more energy and like I'm more
motivated versus in the morning I'm just
so slow today though I'm actually doing
something even crate if you thought
waking up early to workout was crazy I'm
doing something even crazier what I'm
doing another workout later a virtual
workout with the live method so that's
why I'm not gonna get too hard on myself
for not like doing well in my peloton
class um because I have a strength
training session as a live method
virtually later that's crazy I know but
you know what like peloton has gotten me
as far as peloton can get me in terms of
like my mental health and and a little
bit of physical health I definitely am
feeling decent but I gotta get this
tummy in check and only the live mat
they could do that yeah well um I don't
really need the whole like physical
workout thing because I'm in perfect
shape but I hear you on like the
mornings being so difficult and are
literally our whole day our whole job
revolves around the morning and I hate
the feeling feeling like you could have
done better and then you have to wait
like a whole nother day for the next
toast like really give it your all so I
honestly commend you for trying to like
change that because I have that feeling
and I've never tried to do anything
about it
yeah well you know what on day 40 is it
now I've decided to make a change I
don't know that it's gonna stick I don't
think it's gonna stick at all you know I
tried it I'm glad I could say that I
tried it but I do feel like my energy
today is a little more than normal it
definitely is especially considering I
absolutely hate how I look body I don't
know I just like the black isn't working
for me I look so pale
someone should suggested something in my
DM is that I'm not gonna implement yet
but was an interesting suggestion
because when I said I like really wasn't
feeling like super hot they were like
you should try just like doing full glam
at OOTD like going all out you ain't
using heat on your hair and I don't know
if that would make me feel better or
like stupid then I'm sitting here with
globs of makeup on you know and then I
have to take it off I've been seeing a
lot of tic TOCs of people who are like
putting together Black Tie dinners and I
like commend them and their imagination
but it is a little stupid oh I haven't
seen
I haven't seen it yet I'm always a few
days behind the tick tock trends but
that's that's kind of funny
well I am so tired like I don't think
I've had a day as long as and as
productive as I did yesterday in
quarantine and I only was that
productive like I didn't get embed it
till like 7:00 which is crazy for me I
usually get in bed after the toast stay
there all day like watch this stuff for
the toast answer emails do stuff on my
computer but I don't leave my bed but I
did a whole vlog yesterday for our
patreon that if you want to go look at
it's on the patreon um so I've logged
the whole day so I had to like do stuff
like for the vlog I couldn't just like
vlog me in bed and then there was like
such an ordeal with my sheets I tried to
wash my sheets and my laundry machine
got like stuck and my [ __ ] washing my
sheets were stuck in the washing machine
it was very traumatic so if you want to
check out the vlog I worked so hard on
it
I gave so much respect for vloggers I
don't really vlog literally I've logged
from the moment I woke up to like I had
dinner at 8 o'clock so hard so much work
the tripod the lights the cameras the
angles oh my god the silence I need
silence because Ben's in the other room
it was a journey Wow but I'm glad I had
the pleasure of watching the video it's
a real treat and I think everyone really
enjoyed it and if you haven't seen yet
or you're not a member of I'm so jealous
of people who aren't patrons right now
like they could join today and get
access like 180 premium episodes like
there's so many good ones in the archive
you know and that could really that can
really last you like drunk get ready
with us you know there's videos there's
your wedding video there's tons of
podcast episodes I actually was on the
patreon yesterday and it was like sign
up now it wasn't logged in yet and it
said sign up now get access to over 170
episodes that's what I saw - and it was
like 90 videos it was crazy stuff that
is crazy so now's as good as time as
ever patreon.com/scishow morning trust
we have two more episodes coming at you
this month we have one coming up that
was I think a recommendation but Jackie
really put the scheduling into fruition
to get a zoom happy hour with all the
scenes on deck even though like Olivia
can't drink but whatever yeah we're
gonna do that tomorrow I'm really
excited
speaking of Olivia I am doing her
podcast today so I actually have a
really busy day for a quarantine
speaking also of Olivia's podcast I
spoke to Olivia yesterday did you know
that she recorded an app
with Andy Grammer oh my god no I didn't
know that they recorded it yeah no me
neither cuz he just had a baby and
Olivia said it was like the most amazing
conversation and I got Olivia one of
these microphones so she was just really
turning out premium content yesterday
Wow I'm really excited for all of that
all of the other thoughts there's also
new episode today of Lauren Elizabeth
and Margaret Joseph's Margaret Joseph's
is having like a world-class physician
on the toe on the podcast so check that
out all shows toast news network you
guys check it out
and the Senate Judy snatchler the snitch
itty snatch also I'm just gonna plug the
redheads book club because it's my
passion project in life it's my favorite
thing that I'm doing during quarantine
it's just you don't need to explain
yourself okay but like also I just want
to say like I just wanted people to feel
included like even if you've never if
you haven't joined the redheads yet
you've never read one of our books
you've never listened to an episode like
you can start anywhere if it were me I
would start from the beginning and
listen to all the episodes that way you
can get a sense for all of our different
personalities let's start anywhere start
on this next book and jump into the next
episode like we are there we are waiting
for you I just finished a really good
book yesterday it was so intense it was
so crazy called educated and so many
people had recommended it and we're
waiting to see what I thought it was
incredible like it's an incredible story
I didn't really it didn't really sink in
to me until about 50% way through that
it's a true story like I knew that it
was like a memoir sort of I don't really
read the description of the books
but the story is so crazy that it's like
you couldn't make it up because someone
would say you're making this this could
never happen this is too crazy I
understand so it was really it was
powerful stuff does it have anything to
do with the movie and education no but
like except for that you loved that
movie and now I love this book that
would be the only correlation um you
have to watch a movie it's so fabulous
we had this exact conversation on our
zoom Saturday night zoom well I stand by
my statements on Saturday night it's a
fabulous movie for anyone who hasn't
seen it it's a movie that all young
girls should say okay well that's that
on that
take it or leave it and I think it's
time to jump right in because we
actually have a lot to cover today we
have dear toasters Vanderpump rules
recap and as per usual we've got
actually sometimes its usual now it's
different every day but we've got the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and that's true Jackie but I have a very
if you've taken a look at my legs I have
a very pertinent sponsor for today's
show it's Billy
because self-care and your routine are
always important whatever your use
you're using to get ready for the day
always make sure you should feel amazing
meet Billy they've recreated everyday
essentials by delivering premium razors
and high-performing body care directly
to you know pink tax no visit to the
drugstore no breaking the bank go to my
Billy comm to get their starter kit for
just nine dollars that includes their
award-winning razor to refill blades and
a magnetic holder that keeps your razor
safe and dry in between uses Billy is
out to change the way you shave they
just they just released three completely
clean must-have products to add to your
routine a lip balm a dry shampoo and
face wipes so make sure you stock up I
have had a Billy I bought it Billy like
with my own money before they started
sponsoring the shows and I have to say
like having that little magnetic thing
in the shower is so fabulous like I
didn't realize how great razors get like
all rusty and crusty because they're
they're put away wet and they're not
like properly taken care of because men
just like throws it on the floor but but
is not allowed to use my razor I'm like
this is my thing and you can have your
own it's so fabulous Margot actually
told me about it and I bought it from
Margo's Instagram story and now they're
sponsoring the choice and I'm just so
excited because in this quarantine time
like some of my limbs are just reaching
levels of disgusting that I never knew
is possible no I just got my Billy razor
and it is everything of the sort like
first of all looks so key to my bathroom
I love the magnetic holder it's so key
but it's a five blade razor which I feel
like is it's just a great shave it's a
great shave and I couldn't recommend it
highly enough I also got the wipes which
is literally a whole makeup routine like
in one wipe everything I'm so excited
about this monster like so excited
they're the allure best a beauty winner
and on their on nylons be
hitless for a reason go to my Billy
dot-com slash toast a small but you can
support us while getting the best razor
you will ever own
it's just nine dollars to get your
starter kit plus free shipping always go
to my Billy dot-com slash toasts spelled
bi ll is calm my billi bi Li e.com slash
toast Thank You Billy for sponsoring
today's episode and just sketchy legs
bikini line arms whatever you fancy in
check sign on gets silky smooth limbs
okay
first story speaking of beauty Goldie
Hawn Kate Hudson and baby rainy Grace
nope
I'm sorry Goldie Hawn Kate Hudson and
baby grainy great grace year's cover of
people's beautiful issue Wow okay so the
world has stopped turning but people's
beautiful issue has in they have put
forth their new cover of their most
beautiful people and gracing the cover
Kate Hudson Goldie Hawn and Kate
Hudson's little bit
three generations of beautiful women
this is so cute I have such like a soft
spot in my heart for like Kate Hudson
and her whole vibe I think she is
actually the definition of everything of
the sort like she's in so many of my
favorite movies and she really like aged
so gracefully and I just love her even
when she shaved her head and had that
best cut like I loved her support in her
like I just love her yeah I love her I I
love this also like this
multi-generational
vibe every age is beautiful and if I saw
age I would I'd be able to say that but
I don't so it's just beauty and I think
this is this is so lovely and I love
that we're getting like a little bit of
like the normal content that we're used
to in quarantine because there's no
reason that they shouldn't have
published this I'm just glad that it's
still happening yeah this is impressive
like People magazine obviously plans out
really far in advance because everyone's
pretty much been out of commission for
like two months oh well maybe a little
less but that's just goes to prove that
like I wonder how many covers they have
shot you know yeah but their covers are
like tabloid things but when it comes to
like a photoshoot like this I'm now it
got me really excited not really excited
but you know as excited as one can be
for their sexiest man alive issue whoo
you think it's gonna be I don't know I
feel like every time the cover comes out
then everyone gives like a million
choices that would have been great I'm
still holding out hope for Jason Momoa
but I feel like his time has passed yeah
it's like an interesting formula where
it has to be someone who is like having
a moment and it was also really sexy and
I always find it interesting how they
like only choose men in their 40s where
it's like Harry Styles wouldn't win you
know yeah yeah because I think they're
hot Rob I think their readership is
interested in a little bit of an older
man they don't want to be seeing Harry
Styles and thinking that's like sexy you
know this was a great year for Brad Pitt
I was just singing the same thing it was
a great year for Brad Pitt there's so
many choices
anyways let's focus on the women um so
beautiful so cute I love um I just think
that like the fact that Goldie Hawn has
Kate Hudson's mom is like never should
never not chocks me I know but they
really are so similar people's most
beautiful issue always reminds me of
Julia Roberts I feel like she used to
always get the cover when we were kids
like she won 30 years in a row I
actually have the same exact Association
in my brain of this magazine like
edition and Julia Roberts like I the two
for me are inextricably linked me okay
and her smile like it yes like her teeth
her teeth oh yeah okay that is really
crazy but I think this is such a great
choice I I'm here for it and that babba
is cute so cute and speaking of cute
bebés speak
of them Joshua Jackson and Jody Turner
Smith welcomed a baby girl you guys this
is so sweet Joshua Jackson and wife
Joanie Turner Smith our first-time
parents page six can reveal quote the
couple has welcomed their first child
both mother and baby are happy and
healthy the rep did not reveal the sex
of the baby but Turner Smith set off
speculation they were having a girl when
she referred to the baby using the she
pronoun last month she uh she had said
quote can you see her dancing in there
every time I try to she stops she set up
a video of her stomach okay I have a
very very special place in my heart for
Joshua Jackson for many reasons
obviously the affair is one of them
I just think he's like the hottest man
alive like and even his role in big
little lies where he's like not meant to
be hot he's like meant to be like chubby
dad he's so hot he's no little eyes he's
raised with this resentment minifiers
everywhere Oh same thing whatever say
literally same thing um sorry thank you
for correcting me um but part of my
heart like aches a little bit because I
just feel like Diane Kruger it's like
not having a good week who's hold on I
just like he's the one from inglorious
basterds who got choked by Christoph
Waltz okay cuz you know for a second I
thought I was thinking of the woman from
Mad Money yeah Diane Keaton yeah I know
you were I know when I said to her I was
about to say Diane Keaton cuz it's very
similar but they're so different and
dice for Jackson were together forever
and I actually saw them one time buying
a TV at Best Buy and it was literally
the best day of my life like they were
Taylor for so long and they broke up and
he just like so quickly fell in love
with this other girl and I'm really
happy for them and that they're having
kids but like I just feel like Diane
Kruger is having a bad day and I'm
really sad for her okay I understand now
yeah I'm s I'm sad for her even though I
just found out about all this but I'm
mostly happy for Josh and Jodie yeah and
you know it's just so weird because in
the affair um Jodie is that kid with
that he has with Allison join me yeah
whatever so he married his daughter
again her name was Joanie
yeah which was a weird name so uh that
show is a terrible show so you can't go
by anything that happened on it I was a
bet with me for the end till the end of
my life the affair is the worst show
I've ever seen in all my days on this
earth I didn't have such a negative
reaction to it they're attempting it I
can't believe that you like that show
because you have the like the least
patience of anyone there were some
things I definitely didn't like about it
but um like it was a little slow
especially in the beginning where they
were like his perspective her
perspective and you were watching the
same dinner party like that was so
frustrating but overall I did really
liked it
maybe it's because I watched it season
by season like I didn't binge watch it
like maybe if you binge watch something
you really get to see how bad it is but
I was separated week lynnie like
sometimes I even watched it weekly I
just really liked maura Tierney and I
likes the cast I like to I don't know
I'm defending myself
Jackson like I know everyone knows him I
think he's from Dawson's Creek
originally but I first found out about
him from the a bear and I thought he was
so cute yeah I thought he was so cute
colocar justice for him but he had heard
enough for himself yeah yeah okay this
next story is maybe the best news we've
gotten in quarantine um I'm not even
gonna preface it with anything more than
that Ben Platts Radio City Music Hall
concert will debut on Netflix in May
okay I'm so excited about this I wasn't
able to attend the concert none of us
were because he really had the hutzpah
to make the concert in New York at Radio
City that he was filming for Netflix on
Rosh Hashanah which is the Jewish New
Year and he's like Jewish and he went to
Jewish camp like I don't know why he did
that it was actually really
disappointing and like the ones like
issue I've ever had with him but we are
getting a televised event so like it
could feel like I was there I'm so
excited like the artwork was so powerful
I just feel like really like Ben Platt
is like so New York and he's like really
like a theater buff and I feel like they
are going to give like Radio City the
respect it deserves
do you know Damien like the history yeah
the special is called Ben Platt live
from Radio City Music Hall you know
they're putting it in the tight
it's gonna be so good I'm so excited to
see what songs he sings cuz obviously
he'll sing his own songs like rain and
you know all the ones that make you cry
but I'm sure he'll sing some dr ben
hansen yeah definitely some covers it's
gonna be spectacular now here's the
thing it comes out on May 20th and like
I am living my life with the intention
that May 15th is the end of quarantine
so it's gonna be a 5 days too late for
me I'll come home from the big party
I'll be at on May 20th to watch this but
like I'm just like all of my chips are
riding on quarantine ending on May 15th
as the governor heads head and don't say
even if it's not the case you can't say
anything otherwise it's all that's
getting me through you know what I'll
say is that Netflix actually today I saw
a Twitter release like their entire
slate of what's coming out on in the
month of May from like their own content
to like random seasons of random shows
being added and it was really
fascinating because they have the Ryan
where everything there was so much stuff
but I didn't know half of it they have a
new Jerry Seinfeld comedy special coming
out and then two new specials from
people I'd never heard of and they
actually have a lot of good stuff coming
it's like they finally in May decided to
like get on board helping people I get
their quarantine yeah okay wait I found
an article dead to me season two oh yes
Wow that show was so good new comedy
specials from Hannah Gatsby and Jerry
Seinfeld a comedy called space for
starring Steve Carell but I need a break
from him after dinner for Schmucks Oh
romantic action comedy the lovebirds the
Patriot not sure what that is wow I mean
cool good stuff yeah I mean you know
it's not here I'll be watching all of it
up until May 15th see them I will mostly
be watching all of it up until June 1st
stop I mean even though like on May 15
it's not like we're gonna be in a walk
party like in the middle of the street
but still I just one day at a time one
day
dad okay
and now I'm like totally caught up in
this list of things that are coming and
going but whatever we have to move on
because we have some more streaming news
well is it the streaming news that's
brought to you by noon yeah okay I was
just you know there's more than one um
getting in shape doesn't have to be
about losing a specific amount of weight
or a magic number on the scale it's
about building healthier habits and
feeling better about yourself if fitting
into your favorite pair of jeans is your
goal been great but there are many
reasons why you might want to practice
self-care and every person is different
I've really never been one to like try
and draw pounds but sometimes I
definitely want to like get myself back
on track just because it makes me feel
better like my headaches and my fatigue
like it all has to do with what you're
putting into your body and that's why
Noom is so fabulous it is to have a
changing solution that helps users learn
to develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses it's based
in psychology so Noom teaches you why
you do the things you do and empowers
you to with the tools you need to break
bad habits and replace them with better
ones no food is considered good batter
off limits on new they teach you
moderation and it can be used in
conjunction with many preexisting
popular diets if you want because
Newman's not a diet it is a healthy and
easy to stick to way of life they have
one of the biggest and most accurate
food databases available that lets you
track your meal habits visualize your
portion sizes and see calorie density at
a glance we are all strapped for time so
Newman's just asking you to commit to 10
minutes a day for yourself you are human
if you go off track as most of us do
there's absolutely no shaming just tips
to help you get back on track tomorrow
chat with your goal specialist and the
entire new community to get and give
help to people going through the same
thing you don't have to change it all in
one day small steps make big progress
sign up for your trial today at noon
calm / toast that's N oom dot-com /
toast what do you have to lose visit
Noom com / toast to start your trial
today that's n o o m.com
/ toast neem has been one of those like
great life saving things during the
quarantine just like keeping you on
track like helping you reach just little
goals that you need to set for yourself
or that at least that I need to suffer
myself in order to feel like I'm staying
on track and that I'm not going to off
the deep end in quarantine I think it's
a really great aid
this time so sign on what do you have to
lose okay next up HVL max sets official
launch date the streaming wars are
coming to a head y'all warner media has
set the date for HBO max it's slated to
barrel into the streaming Wars on May
27th hmm so that's 12 days after I'll be
out the door the subscriptions this
subscription streaming package with some
10,000 hours of content out of the gate
will debut May 27th in the u.s. priced
at $14.99 monthly the same as HBO now
warner Media announced the launch date
Tuesday after earlier running online ads
with the info I mean a $14.99 a month
it's like steep um I do wish that they
had like gotten their [ __ ] together a
month earlier I think it actually really
would have helped with their like launch
because I actually saw today when I was
looking at that Netflix thing like
Netflix projected during this quarter
they would get 7 million new users and
they ended up getting 11 million new
users because people are so [ __ ]
bored so I think it actually could have
moved them to have release it a month
earlier but they did it I will be
subscribing because they have friends on
there and they have Gary janetti's show
about Prince George which looked
hilarious
[ __ ] I was about to say I won't be
subscribing because none of this sounds
like things that I need here's what
here's what they had they have
third-party licensed content like
Friends Big Bang Theory South Park
they're also putting out originals like
a scripted comedy called love life
starring Anna Kendrick great oh yeah a
documentary film on the record about
accusations of sexual harassment and
rape against hip-hop mogul Russell
Simmons legendary and underground
ballroom dance competition series craft
topia hosted by YouTube star Lowe
laurdiy and on the Looney Tunes cartoons
from Warner Brothers animation and
sesame workshop's the not to late show
with Elmo so it's premium content but
just I don't know that it's premium for
me but you know what like am I gonna
have to pay $15 a month to watch Gary
Jannetty show about Prince George
I might or I just might need to borrow
your login yeah well we'll get a
and um that ballroom dancing show is the
show that we spoke about a little while
ago that got like a lot of controversy
for selecting Jameela Jamil as the host
or one of the judges I forget what her
role is
I saw trailer for it and it looks really
good ooh exciting um so I look forward
to using your login I'll check that out
you know I belongs to B yes yeah but
I'll have to be able to find time to
watch it cuz it'll be on May 27th and I
won't be here anymore
where you can be just like parties here
there everywhere parks um clubs rest did
you see those paparazzi pictures of
Margaret kweli and her mom Andie
MacDowell sneaking out of a park that
was closed in Beverly Hills like
literally climbing under the gate like
like thieves
yeah and you know what like I can relate
no but like it the fact that they got
caught by the paparazzi is crazy
yeah those pictures were actually
hilarious they're like not that famous
that they would get like paparazzi
non-stop yeah I guess I don't know maybe
that's actually very interesting cuz I
feel like most of time when people get
paparazzi they've called them
I don't know that Andie MacDowell almost
nine out of ten times I would say the
person getting paparazzi did had their
publicist organized the paparazzi so
it's like maybe some paparazzo just got
lucky me but now I'm I just search turn
apparently she is getting backlash for
sneaking into the park because obviously
like it's closed for a reason um that is
really so crazy she was with her two
daughters right I'm obsessed with her
other daughter which one not not the
Pete Davidson ex-girlfriend one the
other one her name is rainy and she's a
singer and when I worked at I heart she
like came and they did those small
little performance and she was literally
the most talented girl I've ever seen in
my life really rainy kweli rainy quali
yeah that's crazy
I know and so like justice for her
justice for her mom and her anti-aging
skincare routine because it seems to be
working you know they seem like a really
cute family I really like it and
McDowell and I feel like
has good daughters I mean I don't know
what she actually is famous for but like
in my book she's famous for her iconic
role of like a Charlotte York type in um
beauty shop with Queen Latifah Oh
interesting
to me the most recent thing that I saw
her in was a hallmark film called the
beach house with her and Minka Kelly and
it was a fabulous felt like it was sort
what I don't it wasn't even I don't
think it was like a Hallmark Channel
original it was on another level it was
you should check it out it was giving me
like last song vibes but like what is
she from like what what's wrong heard of
Fame Andie MacDowell I love just having
like all the internet access here when I
look at her on Wikipedia
Oh oh my god Groundhog Day oh I've never
seen it but I know what it is you have
to see it no I know the concept like he
wakes up it's the same day sounds like
torture why would I want to put myself
through that because it's iconic and
then every time we use this saying like
it feels like Groundhog Day
now you understand no but I understood
it before like without seeing no but
like do you until you go through the
suffering of what it would really be
like if every day we're the same it was
like the alarm clock wakes up like oh my
god it's the same day I'm familiar yeah
you've been getting I don't know if it's
a quarantine thing or just like a me
thing but I am getting like bald spots
in my eyebrows and it's really freaking
me out you see it I guess I you've
always had that though like you're
always throwing it in this eyebrow now
it's in the right I think it's you thing
I don't I don't think you can blame that
one on the queue why not you know
actually do it I was doing my eyebrows
today and they're getting so long I'm
gonna start to look like Count Olaf
where they start to twist at the end you
know what you need Jackie hmm I've been
this little pouch of gadgets okay well I
don't know that that's really
appropriate right now
facial hair scissors are every now and
I'm not touching my eyebrows why oh my
god stop put that down
I feel like a teacher put your words
away hands on the desk what hands where
I could see em
okay bid them final story are you ready
both are you ready for a cousin final
story class yeah
Hunger Games prequel The Ballad of
songbirds and snakes moves forward at
Lions Gate with series director Francis
Lawrence Hunger Games series filmmaker
Francis Lawrence is returning to helm
the Lionsgate prequel The Ballad of song
birds and snakes based on Suzanne
Collins new Scholastic novel which will
be available for sale on may 19th in the
US Canada the UK Ireland Australia and
New Zealand so we're getting more Hunger
Games because she's coming out with a
new book it's probably not gonna be the
same cast but same vibe because it's the
same filmmaker and I'm here for it
so we're thinking this is like a start
of a new franchise like not really
having anything to do with the old one
well I think it will be based actually I
feel like I remember reading it was kind
of it's a prequel to the people that we
know so it's like what made them maybe
all go into districts like that initial
rebellion that may always like talk
about maybe something like that I just
feel like it's been so long since the
actual Hunger Games franchise was
relevant like if this is a direct like
sequel or prequel like who [ __ ] cares
it's so late but if it's like its own
thing um I could be interested i think
it's its own thing like i think i can
actually even read this book not having
like been a hunger games' stand reading
the other books and enjoy it yeah well i
don't really plan on reading this book
and probably not gonna see the movie but
i'll be curious to see the casting
yeah me too and you know what they
wanted to be a smash smash success they
should choose two people who are gonna
fall in love on set like that's all you
need two key ingredient perfect formula
perfect formula well that's exciting um
those are five stories i feel like it's
you know didn't a lot of stuff for the
future that we are can be excited for
and as of today we're just gonna be
excited alexa is talking to me i haven't
spoken to her since i moved into this
apartment in any over a year I haven't
spoken to that [ __ ] and now she's
talking to me
oh my cheese listening she's listening
go back to sleep
a lot she's Hey go to sleep go to sleep
what she said something
the Wi-Fi network maybe zach is trying
to connect just leave me alone okay oh
well it's like a ghost please stop
I didn't unplug it really that's all you
could come up with Jill the time
I muted her so she thought I was talking
to her now she'll she'll learn today
she'll learn today all right let's jump
into our TV recap segment because we
need to recap Vanderpump rules and I
want to talk about a show that I just
started watching our TV recap segment is
brought to you by mazury mazury is
everything you need they are the most
fabulous handcrafted ethically sourced
and made to last jewelry it is the
perfect gift that you could find for
Mother's Day anyone you love they make
fine jewelry for every day where they
don't have the ten times markups they
take the guesswork out of gifting
offering everything from dainty 14 karat
solid gold pieces to pearls diamonds
gemstones and more they have unlimited
options and you could chop their gifts
under 150 dollars or you can make it
personal with an engraving I love an
engraved jewelry moment if you can't
decide they also have a curated gift
guide they take care of the rest it can
give frapp they ship and you can get
free shipping on all US and canada
orders plus easy returns and a two-year
warranty I've been wearing Missouri
because Lauren Elizabeth used to post
about them all the time and it really is
like the perfect like when I'm on
tick-tock and I see all these girls like
being so cute with their like dainty
gold jewelry like I just know that they
when they take that jewelry off there's
a big green line on their pick and I
just don't want that like I want
epically sourced and I want legit
14-karat and that's why I shop it
Missouri and that's why my tick tock is
fly head to Missouri comm slash toast or
use the Koto's to check out for 10% off
your first order
that's Maj URI dot-com slash toast for
10% off your first order
again that's Missouri mej you are i.com
slash toast they gave me sherry for
sponsoring this episode and this
Vanderpump rules recap segment and I'm
sorry for all the bad things I'm about
to say about banner
because it was such another like
overproduced boring nothing sauce
episode yeah we still didn't get an
engagement so now it's like we'll get it
next week but this is a four week
lead-up to an engagement I think the
most interesting pivotal iconic scene I
came out of this episode was Sheena
gifting Jana a psychic medium for her
birthday so that her mom could celebrate
with her and that they could talk and
that was just like the craziest thing
I've ever seen in my life and it makes
it so crazy that I actually don't think
like it could have been cooked up by a
producer so now I'm just curious like
truly what were Sheena's motivations
that was wild and then to lie well so it
was really really uncomfortable
um I I'm of the mindset and I feel like
we're gonna disagree that Sheena was
like actually trying to do something
nice and I and Sheena maybe has lived in
LA for so long that she didn't really
foresee Dana like getting upset about it
like everyone in LA like loves a psychic
I actually saw it and when scheana said
it I was like oh my god that's so sweet
and I did not expect a night AB like
such an adverse reaction to it and I do
think it was weird that Sheena lied but
I understood why she lied like Dana was
so visibly uncomfortable like she didn't
want it to feel like an ambush I think
Sheena genuinely thought it was gonna be
like a nice thing that Dana was like not
into and that's why she know like I ran
out and tried to get the UM psychic to
just [ __ ] leave like I really don't
think scheana had bad intentions here
like I'm choosing to believe scheana
okay I can choose to believe scheana
because I can't I don't I can't imagine
a world where someone like uses
someone's like dead parent and a psychic
medium to manipulate a situation um and
and I would agree that she you know
tried to cover it up but like really
what kind of delusional person like
maybe you can think this is a nice thing
to do like to scut to you know gift
someone this gift but to spring it like
that's something that you need like time
to like I'm gonna set aside time and I'm
gonna you know meet with this media I'm
not like and here is a communication
like I just to bring her to her house
like that was just so crazy I just feel
like Sheena is just so it's clear that
she's never been through a grief like
that or else she would know that you
don't just bring that on some
and have someone show that you have you
lost a parent
my mom has so no yeah that was just that
was so so crazy but whatever I really
did feel bad for Sheena and that seemed
like it seemed really genuine like when
she was presenting the gift she thought
it was gonna be like so well received
like she had tears in her eyes and like
that was just not how it went and I
actually if somebody did that to me like
I actually I don't know if I was filming
a reality show but like I would really
appreciate that gift like that's really
nice like I would say to my dad in 15
years it's like maybe he'll come through
but I do understand why someone wouldn't
want it and especially in front of
someone who's like not really been like
such a good friend to them like I see
Dana's hesitancy but I do didn't she was
like a little harsh
um I don't think she was harsh at all
like I think the whole situation was
beyond strange I just think like Dana's
not LA enough to to be down with
something like that and I completely
understand yeah I just I really like it
takes a lot for me to feel for scheana
and I really did because I thought she
was trying to be nice and like this is
her version of like reaching out I guess
okay but let's continue to talk about
the younger sect and then we'll get into
the alumni because it's two separate
shows and the younger crew like going
tonight and Gayle giving me the hills
vibes like with their big table their
outdoor area for filming like I thought
it was fabulous you know I didn't get a
Hills vibe I actually got like a
mary-kate and Ashley teen Club vibe um
where they were like in a fake club and
it was just beyond state it was like
staged in a strange like I feel like the
club wasn't even open that night and
they just like got them and some extras
to sit around a table and like I don't
know
it was very MK and Ashley to me oh
that's so funny I actually really liked
it like the total scene shift the whole
cast shift like it looked so fun like I
really enjoyed it really was giving me
like a vibe of the hills like Vanderpump
rules kids like have somehow had a hit
reality show without ever going to like
an actual cool place like they're always
going like random places in LA that way
and they just go to sur and pump you
know but even when they let go to the
Mondrian they're only going on
Andriana obviously have some sort of
arrangement with the Mondrian they're
just like they're supposed to be like
these fabulous kids in LA and they're
like never going anywhere cool yeah but
I think it's just cuz they have all the
places that they need to go have you
ever heard of the nightingale yeah
okay I was convinced it was like a fake
club that they set up well it all said
so fake no I I think it's like a cool
Club in LA I don't know like the LA club
scene like I know the New York went like
them back in my hand but I do think that
it's like a cool spot so I was just like
excited to see them being cool hot young
reality stars like that's what they are
and it's about time that they start
acting like it
well I'm glad that they were able to
pass that off to you as a cool young
hobby ality star vibe to me it was like
and they were at a soundstage no but
honestly the scene was like it was fun
and different but it really cemented for
me that Danica is the absolute whoa like
I really want her off my screen or I'm
gonna stop watching ya so I'm not crazy
about the suspended manager her that is
Danica but she's attempting to give us a
show here and I appreciate it a little
bit I don't even know what it I don't
even know what I would like and what I
don't like anymore all I know I said
it's just not working but I can't figure
out what element isn't working for me um
I could tell you what element of the
show is not working for me and it's
really it's genuinely hard because I
really actually have come to really like
James Kennedy I think that he is really
on a good path and I think that he's a
good person and I'm a ride-or-die for
Lyle I can't like I think she's the
baddest [ __ ] in the game but scenes of
them singing and like getting in the
studio like will never ever ever make me
like comfortable like I just feel so
weird about it like in the songs like I
just can't I loved it like obviously I'm
not gonna be listening to the song on my
Spotify um but they obviously enjoy it
so much to the point where they don't
even really care like what people think
of them and their music even though I'm
sure you know it doesn't hit the charts
but they just keep putting it out cuz
they genuinely enjoy doing it um and I
just think it's like a fun hobby for
them and they really connect on so many
different levels in and outside the
studio now I actually thought that was
one of my favorite scenes
just like talking about their new paths
Oh totally and I agree like this studio
was like this therapeutic moment for
them but the singing and the songs is
just not um it okay but like think of it
more as a hobby and then I think you
won't be so pressed by it no it's just
like the way they get in there like I
didn't know it's gonna be a smash of
banging like that like so Kanye like I
just want to die when they talk about
music but I like I really like them both
and I like that they have this vessel
which they can like communicate and and
like connect yes okay I don't disagree
with all of that um so let's talk about
the alumni yeah Jackson Britney we're
like not in the episode it really
revolves around that witches of we hope
RT and to be honest like I haven't
really been like a Christian sympathizer
for um pretty much the entire season and
I'm now when it comes to Kristen and
Stassi like I'm really standing firmly
in the middle because I do think
stassi's being really harsh with Kristen
just like cutting her out of her life
and I get what Stassi saying like why do
I need to explain myself
um to anyone I just want stop being
friends with someone but like you all
you two have this business so with the
business stuff like I really sided with
Kristen but then with the hobo thing
like I thought Christian was being
inappropriate like Stassi doesn't wanna
be your friend like that includes beau
sorry yeah she was being inappropriate
like trying to get beau to say some
stuff like about Stassi being
controlling like here's the thing
there's two types of people in this
world like people who are in a
relationship and it's like we are
together we a ride-or-die my friends are
your friends my enemies are your enemies
and we are a team for life and then
there's other people who are like oh
well just because your don't you hate
someone doesn't mean I can't be friends
of them I'm not one of those people like
I am a teammate ride-or-die your team is
my team and I'm Stassi in that way so
Kristen trying to make her seem like
she's controlling a vote it's not like
that it's just a loyalty thing like like
you're afraid of her like that was so
[ __ ] up like no no that's called being
a good boyfriend on the same way like
Ben if I hit someone you better [ __ ]
hate them too and if anyone
anything to been like a literally
comments up their throat in the night
I'm deciding about being a good
boyfriend I actually think that's the
it's the separation it's about being a
good partner so when someone is just
your boyfriend or girlfriend yeah don't
make enemies and friends because of them
because it's fair-weather and then
you're you're stuck in these messes when
you eventually break up but like bo
knows that Stassi is his life partner
therefore like they are on the same team
on anything Kristen just sees everything
is like boyfriend/girlfriend like oh you
don't need to choose her for me we're
all just friends but it's not like that
anymore nning I don't think she's get
that's the part that she's not getting
where it's not like oh I'm gonna be
friends with Jax and Luke's we maybe had
sex and that's your boyfriend because
everything was so like really nearly
back in the day but now it's like these
are life partners and life plans and
you're getting in the way of that yeah
like it's serious like we're getting a
house I agree I don't think Kristen
understands like the gravity of their
relationship um but you know Stassi is
very much like an alpha female and I
feel like she definitely wears the pants
in that relationship so I really did
like appreciate both standing up for
himself but not just like chasing after
Stassi and like getting yelled at and
like being a [ __ ] like I appreciated
that because it takes it's a certain
type of guy to be with someone like
Stassi like bold outspoken like she's
very much an alpha female and I like
that bow like so held his own even
though I didn't really agree with him
yeah III agree with that um also when it
comes to the witches of leha wine stuff
am I the only one that finds it like so
fascinating yes it's a part it's the
most interesting part there's so many
different elements first of all Stassi
like saying that their Destiny's Child
and she's Beyonce because she obviously
has this like blossoming career and so
much going on outside of this wine thing
that is holding her back and taking up
her time and energy and she does she
can't even bother to post about it like
that is so fascinating the fact that
like they came out with this wine and
then like had no business plan or we're
like it's just so fascinating about the
Katie like Kristen's getting all the
decorations like I understand that
Stassi is beyond busy what is Katie
doing yes so basically what I got from
the live tweets Katie and Kristen were
like going at it and Katie was basically
being like we did this partnership like
this wine was like a licensing deal with
knocking points like knocking point set
up the decorations knocking point set up
the party we were just supposed to show
up and post on Instagram like that was
only our job that was the only job that
we had
and it was clear that Kristen like went
above and beyond because I don't think
Chris and I was like as much as Stassi
going on she has like her t-shirt
company and she's on Vanderpump rules
so she threw a lot into this like she
came up and she put in sweat equity like
she didn't have to but it was a brand
that she was like passionate about and
wanted to make it a big deal so it was
kind of like Katie did what was required
Kristen went above what was required and
Stassi just like barely did anything got
it okay well it makes me happy to know
that it was a licensing deal I mean you
have to assume that it was because you
don't just like overnight have a wine
company and they like have a
contradiction man he actually just like
vases they lent their names to something
and it was a good idea for a company but
just not when it's like based on a
friendship that's foundation is rocky
and no one wants to do it honestly like
after this I mean if I had bought which
is a we whole wine and like saw how
nobody wanted to do it I would feel so
like slighted as a customer like I would
just feel like an idiot for like
believing these Instagram posts are
sorry if anyone bought it but they
should really I'm sure the contract is
up by now like Kristen should continue
to do it because honestly I feel like
the brand when I think of it like I
really associated with Kristen and I she
was happy with it like if they would
have her I think she should continue the
wine on her own and I feel like in every
scene of the show Kristen is drinking
wine 100% she's like always bid and
she's like she's so wine she so she's
always like drinking wine on her couch
in a tank top in a James May tank top
yeah I would agree with that
um they definitely need a rebrand um but
it was just really interesting the whole
the whole thing I found interesting and
it was kind of sad because if it had
worked out like I actually think it
could have been like a really big brand
the branding was too cute in potions
like I think that it could have been
something legit but now when I think
back I'm like what I thought about their
wine company before I saw these episodes
it was like oh that kind of thing that
they just like would post about and but
it's ever really like if you have a wine
like that is it's in every story it's
here it you know it's like Kaitlyn
Bristowe has a wine company total
Bella's have a wine company and
everything is Bella Bella Bella you know
and this was just like every six months
we're contracted to do a post you can
yeah you could tell it was like a
authentic partnership and which sucks
because I think if it was done properly
like it actually could have been
fabulous the branding was so cute I love
that they called all the different
flavors potions like I thought it was
really well done from like a branding
perspective but then like it just didn't
seem like anyone's heart was in and I
literally forgot about it ya know I
think Stassi put it best like their
Destiny's Child but Beyonce has like a
whole thing going on ahead of her and
it's not gonna work out um I also want
to recap are we done with Hannibal
Buress oh one more thing
I loved drunk Arianna like at the wine
party like her getting why drunk I feel
like we don't see her drunk yeah but I
feel like we do I feel like no one's
ever saying that she's not drinking you
know I feel like she drinks but like I
don't think we've ever seen her like
visibly like loopy yeah she is P being
cute
yeah and when she was talking allall
about getting in the studio he's so
happy like that was really cute yeah um
I want to talk about too hot to handle
which I started on Netflix I'm three
episodes in um at first I was about to
turn it off like it was just so dumb
these people were like so dumb and it
was just like dumb dumb dumb it was like
it was giving me are you the one are you
the dumb like it was just like dumber
than are you the one but I'm really glad
that I stuck with it because it's a good
show I know it's just like not my show
I'm glad that I stuck with it because it
was it turned it's turning into a really
really good show and I'm really like get
loving some people and so this will mean
nothing to you but to those watching I'm
only on episode 3 absolutely but I now
I'm totally like now that you said it's
like are you the one which I absolutely
love
I'm gonna watch and I have no plans
after my second workout today so okay so
I will shut the [ __ ] up and we can recap
it and let's assign that and maybe recap
it on Thursday because I don't know if
I'm gonna finish it today okay cool
too hot to handle let's do it juwatch
handle um so we're gonna dive into dere
toasters now which is our today's
segment and it is brought to you by
function of beauty we all know the
frustration bottles and bottles of half
you shampoos and conditioners piling up
in your bathroom each one promised to be
everything your hair ever needed but
they lied to you you deserve better
try function of beauty we don't all have
the same hair so I should be all of the
same shampoo and conditioner you don't
have to
Beauty if you're ready to live your best
hair life in 2020 then you need to try
it it is the Internet's top-rated
customized haircare brand with over
30,000 five-star customer reviews curly
a straight naturally processed function
of beauty individually formulates every
bottle based on your unique hair type
style preference and hair goals to begin
the short for question quiz and save 20%
off your first purchase go to function
of beauty.com slash toast tell them
about your hair customize your formula
with fragrance in color you can go dye
free fragrance free the products are so
personalized your name is even printed
on the bottle it is vegan and
cruelty-free they never use sulfates
parabens flatulates mineral oils or any
other harmful ingredients to get started
right now what a function of beauty.com
/ toast to take your ford part hair
profile quiz and save 20% on your first
order don't spend another minute in hair
misery go to function of beauty calm /
toast
that's function of beauty calm / toast
we love function of eating
we love function of beauty it's all over
my patreon day in the life video like I
just I'm absolutely obsessed with my
bottles I love how they smell
Zack uses literally it every single day
um and I don't mind cuz his hair smells
good it smells like eucalyptus that's
beautiful I'm let's jump into Jojo sirs
our advice segment if you are looking
for advice you can always email us too
dear toasters at gmail.com we always
keep it anonymous and we're talking
anything from quarantine things to
wedding things anything so her first up
steer toasters from the toaster and
stress a friend of mine hmm a friend of
Mines sister Jane has been dating her
boyfriend for 7 years let's call him
Karl a year or two ago at a small party
Karl was caught sneaking into the
bedroom of the couple hosting and stole
pennies out of their dresser the couple
both saw called him out were utterly
disgusted and no longer interacted with
Karl everyone else at the party knows
about the situation but has since swept
it under the rug every now and then it
comes up how weird it was and people
have rumored that he does it frequently
and even mentioned how terrible they
feel for Jane do we the thing is we
think that Jane has no idea about her
boyfriends alarming behavior do we tell
her do I tell her sister when I'm
actually friends with to pass it on to
Jane should I write in a nonnamous
letter please help xox out the toaster
in distress
wow that's really hard you know what I'm
gonna go ahead and say that Jane does
not know
that her man does this and I think that
she if the whole world knows like she
should know um I would tell her sister
and let her sisters problem and her
sister might know her better enough to
say whether she might already know or
she wouldn't care or she shouldn't know
she like leave it to the cysts yeah
definitely don't like stick your nose in
too hard by telling the sis telling Jane
like you just tell the sister but Jackie
had you uh that sparks a question what
would you do if you found out Zack went
to parties and stole underwear out of
people's drawers um that would be really
difficult to grapple with I guess like
we wouldn't go to parties anymore and we
would just like have to find the source
of this like kleptomania and like
perversion yeah so we would have like a
lot I think of therapy ahead of us wow
you're good wife that like your thought
process is automatically like let's work
on this cuz if I hung up and went to
parties and stole girl's underwear it's
like you best believe I'm packing his
things and leaving them outside I know
like I'm but I would also just be
curious it's like why are you doing this
like let's figure it out and then who's
to say after all the therapy like I
might find the gum mound a tissue said I
just am not equipped to handle that's
true well to this toaster in distress
definitely get involved but not too
involved yeah this is like if I found
that Ben was stealing underwear party's
like I know exactly how I would handle
it to you which is how I knew pack your
bags get a car let's go and if your
friend told you about that like let's
say your friend Becky told you about
that like I wouldn't want you to tell me
not Becky no offense I love her but like
of course and also like let me do my own
vetting so like if Becky came to you and
said that you'd be like you don't even
know Ben what are you talking about but
if I like Becky told me I was do a
little bit of research recon you know
see what other parties he's been at see
if there's been any police reports of
missing underwear and then I would come
to you with all the information and so
that you wouldn't doubt me
that's good advice all right next up
dear Claudia Jackie and Theo I am a
toaster from Australia and I've been
living and working in the u.s. now for
four years I have been with my boyfriend
for three years we are in our mid-20s
and yes we've talked about marriage and
our future we both know that each other
are the one with the coronavirus
happening I'm in jeopardy of losing my
job which is tied to my work visa giving
me 60 days to either leave the US or try
and be able to stay in the country my
dilemma is should we just go ahead and
start the process of getting married now
such as applying for spousal visa while
I still have a job or wait until I get
laid off and then rush everything which
could mean I might have to go back home
to Australia and not know when I get to
see him again
crikey I'm stressed crikey this is
stressing through crikey I don't know I
feel like rushing into getting a
marriage visa and everything just
because like of your job is so rash but
at the same time like if you don't and
then like you wish you had that's like a
terrible spot to be in yeah but I've
been reading my newsletter every morning
that visas are being put on hold right
now
um I don't know if it applies to marital
visas but I would I would if you know
this person is your person like I would
deal with the logistical side first and
I would apply for that visa you don't
want to like have to be separated for so
long um so I would try and figure that
out if you can I don't even know if you
can right now but I would try that first
and I think if you know this is your
person then don't worry about rushing
things like things are being rushed some
things are being delayed it's just you
know it's this great time can I just
yeah you know what I was gonna say like
we got so used to like being the three
co-hosts the unstoppable three they were
calling us and he just like hasn't been
on a show in weeks and we miss him
precious angel fisherman beauty boy I
really miss him like you guys know I
haven't seen him now since the last time
we did a show in the studio and it's
been devastating absolutely devastating
um should we go into our third one or do
any other advice for this girl um my
advice for this girl is just like
explore I'll explore all avenues don't
write anything off because you think
it's too soon like if you are certain
that this is your person go down every
road that you can go down yeah that's a
they if you are certain so just do a
lick a small amount of self-reflection
she sounds certain of course
so did Princess Diana
no no she did not sound certain okay
finally hi Claudia and Jackie I hope
you're staying healthy and sane during
this crazy time I have a story for two
toasters that I need advice on I went to
my lake house over quarantine and ended
up hooking up with my kid neighbor who's
a teen for reference I'm 27 and I'm
confused about the situation we have a
weird attraction but it's completely
ridiculous to think that something will
happen in the future I live in a big
city he lives in a small town where I'm
from and have no plans to move back to
anyway I just need your thoughts is this
situation creepy it's it okay if I
continue to talk to him do I need to
feel bad about sleeping with someone
nine years younger than me any advice is
appreciated XO mrs. Robinson PS in case
you're wondering I did not take his
virginity
whew I don't know I kind of think this
is cute like what's wrong with having a
lake house boyfriend like I don't think
there's anything wrong with that this is
so conflicting for me because as you
know I don't see age so this is just the
story about like two people falling in
love at the lake but I'm aware that age
is more than a number sometimes and so
on the one hand I'm like 18 that is so
young and 27 is that's a really big
difference but then on the other hand
I'm out here shipping Scott Disick and
Sophia Richie and so I have to use
everything with that lens of life but I
ship them but they're also
tried-and-true two years of the in a
happy relationship so I have absolutely
no idea what to tell you like I don't
want age to be a factor but like there
is a major difference between an 18 year
old boy and 27 year old woman and it's
like it's not even just like physical
age it's just like mentally to like yeah
because they say that like boys mature
about five years after women so
technically you're hooking up with a 13
but I kind of think it's fine like as
long as you're not really trying to like
be his girlfriend there anything like I
just think it's so hypocritical that we
would think like a cool 18 year old
talking about the cool 27 year old it's
like so cool but like now that the roles
are diverse get it get your man I don't
care you know you want to go to the lake
and you wanna get boned by your 18 year
old neighbor like I think that's cool
but don't fall in love with him and stop
texting him yeah um I honestly like I
have I guess 18 it's legal you know so
so what can we say you know you know I
think I would need to see him like what
kind of 18 is he because I'm us in the
18 year old really weighing 90 pounds
but then I know some 18 year olds like
tik-tok who like lick their lips for a
living and like they looked 35 so I just
need a photo yeah and it's like John B
was 16
right no see that's the thing it's like
our perception is so [ __ ] up because
we're watching John B who's literally in
Outer Banks he's almost 30 in real life
playing 16 year old oh he's almost 30 in
real life Benny wanted Oh interesting
okay yeah um I'm I'm gonna sit this one
out because I really don't know
he's 27 John Bay he's 27 okay well now I
don't feel like as weird what couldn't
they make them like 18 like summer after
college or something no I mean okay I
understand that you can't get a 16 year
old because you want them to be like
handsome but like a 22 year old like
what's with the 27 year old yeah that's
that's a stretch I thought we were like
done doing that putting 30 year olds in
high school movies putting the Pretty
Little Liars girls who are like pregnant
and having kids in middle school totally
honestly I feel very strongly that like
you should keep hitting hooking up with
this 18 year old you know like when
you're gray and old and 50 and your
titties hit the floor like you're gonna
think about that hot 18 year old by the
lake and like you should serve that
memory I think you should do it okay
Claud I'm gonna I'm gonna let you take
this one
if the pandemic has taught us anything
it's that you know like this crazy like
you never know what's gonna happen
bang the 18 year old next to her except
maybe you should watch that movie with
JLo where she bangs her like kids friend
and he turns out to be like a serial
killer wow that was a really tough one I
look forward to an update and a photo
and I also look forward to hearing what
other toasters think about it I'm just
like really on the fence yeah I feel
like maybe it would be fun if we started
doing master posts in the Facebook group
about the deer toasters because
sometimes I really like to get other
people's perspective yeah I I love that
idea I think we should do that because I
also like like to know people agree with
us like if we're giving good advice or
not totally more often than not not but
whatever well now I have to think of it
like I actually am 27 and I'm married
but say one of my friends was hooking up
with the 18 year old next door at their
lake house what would I say to them and
I think it would depend
on where the the friend is in their life
like if the friend is like really
partying a lot and you know sleeping
with a lot of guys and she's on like a
downward spiral I would say this isn't
good but if this girl has like a great
job and she's fun and she's having fun
for the summer like I think that's okay
I don't know I actually think I would
tell a friend no no I would tell a
friend to go for it for sure like just
for fun Wow okay so now do what you want
with that advice yeah that was our
toaster segment please email us dear
toasters at gmail.com if we have read
some of your advice in the past recent
weeks please end you want to update us
email us we will read it on air if you
want us to if not we just saw curious
and you can email any inquiries for
advice at dear toasters at gmail.com
anything and anything we talk about so
that's our show anything else chats
before we go no that's it for us we'll
be back tomorrow I'm so excited for
Beverly Hills tonight and I hope
everyone has an easy Ishta in the queue
we want to reiterate a big fat thank you
to all of our health care workers
essential workers truck drivers everyone
who is out there working making the
world continue to turn and keeping
people healthy and safe me thank you
immensely
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast millennium Morning
Show where we do live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also the ELSA podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that's about if
I iTunes stitcher public radio I heard
Cass box oh the places where ever you
listen to podcast - morning toast if I
serve you about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are we love you guys very
much we'll see you tomorrow bye